so here's what we're going to do in this
segment we do this from time to time and
when we ask you respond with plenty of
great questions we're going to open up
the mailbag that we have compiled and
let's get started with a guy who's going
to be the top of conversation chris over
the next several weeks and has been over
the past several weeks cam newton one
panther place asked this if the liz
frank heals correctly do you see any
reason why cam newton couldn't play at a
high level for another four or five
years i i don't i don't see any reason
why he wouldn't be able to
continue to be an upper echelon's qb i
you know again
it's
he's a guy that's been beat up we know
that yes
uh he plays a different style of game
than most quarterbacks but this is one
of the more physically gifted freaky
guys we've ever seen in the league and
yes at his age i think he's done a
pretty good job of taking care of his
body you know you could see that the the
proof is in the pudding there a little
bit to where yeah i do i think he's
going to be the guy we saw in 2015
no you know do i think his game will
have to adjust to maybe being a little
bit more of a pocket passer yes but i
think he can do that and i think he's
still got a number of good years left in
his career yeah i agree with you the
question i have isn't getting him
healthy though it's weird yeah i know
next injury right once he's healthy is
the shoulder again is it the foot is the
ankle is it this and and there's
something going on between cam newton
and the panthers where you know the
panthers are out there saying we want
him we want him we want him he's putting
these videos on social media where he
says among other things i just want to
be appreciated he's due to make 19
million this year and it's easy to say
we're not going to give a new contract
because we don't know if he's gonna be
healthy well the reason he's not healthy
is because of everything he's given to
the team he is woefully below market
value and i could see him wanting a new
deal even if he's not 100 yeah and
that's going to be a potential pressure
point between the panthers and newton
and i still don't rule out a trade chris
no i know the panthers have been trying
to throw water on it but that's trade
leverage
i'd say the chargers make the most sense
chargers pick up the phone and get you
some cam newton if you want to put butts
and legs in the seats at your new state
i think he's coming out and saying
things like hey i want to be just be
appreciated it's his little way to go
like kind of to set that narrative like
i shouldn't be being paid this i'm on
the last year of a deal and you know
it's kind of his way to kind of
have a little crack in the door to say i
want out of here i think i fully expect
when he passes the physical in a few
weeks that we will start to hear that
carolina's looking to move on from cam
newton and start a new era uh at the
quarterback position or whatever and
that they try to trade cam newton i
really do i just think there's too much
too much changing going on for for both
sides here you know i think matt rule
and joe brady and all them they're
trying to you know instill their own
culture here and and start a new era in
carolina and i think cam newton is
probably like wow that that's a lot to
go through and i think he probably needs
a fresh start as well i think he will be
in another team when all said and done
as our guy darren gant who covered the
panthers for years surmised yesterday
when news broke that trey turner the
offensive lineman in carolina is
available in trade right if he's
available in trade uh-huh ham's
available on trade and let's take it
let's folks i want to put something on
your radar screen for the month of april
christian mccarthy isn't showing up for
anything until he gets paid and uh
depending upon what he wants and it
would be foolish for the panthers not to
move heaven and earth to keep this guy
he had a thousand yards rushing he had a
thousand yards receiving
but uh
look he's not showing up and that's
going to be one of the first big
challenges for david tepper as owner and
matt rule is coach forget about cam
newton for now they're going to have to
solve the christian mccaffrey problem
chris and it's not going to be easy no
it won't be and this is going to be the
new thing with the top tier running
backs in football and i don't blame them
i mean it's you know as you and i have
talked about many times you know if you
ask me you know it's the most physical
position of all sports it's worse than
being a heavyweight boxer or doing
anything like that so i'm always for the
running back trying to get that second
contract as quickly as they can as soon
as they have leverage
next question from at its laker time
what would be your thoughts on a
potential nick foles and frank reich
reunion in indianapolis that's been
inspired by some reporting that isn't
all that firm it's more based on
whispers and chatters from indianapolis
i think espn had this one yesterday
that the the the jaguars are open to the
idea of trading nick foles and giving
the starting job the gardner mentioned
and i've said in the past that that may
be the ideal solution you don't want to
have fault not that falls would foles
would be the perfect guy to be the
backup gardener minshee because he
wouldn't he wouldn't be a negative
presence he'd be a positive person but
it's a lot of money if you can unload
the contract maybe you should do the
cults make sense yeah it's uh well
you're right it's a lot of money and
also it is a negative presence even
without being a negative president
because as soon as gardner minshew has a
game where he throws three interceptions
everyone's gonna start to go well they
do have nick falls should they throw him
back in there and that's where it's
negative as far as the development of a
young quarterback i thought about the
nick foles from you know frank reich
indianapolis colts thing certainly i
have you know i i don't think it happens
i don't see it happening first off you
know what so they're going to pay jacoby
brissette and nick foles a lot of money
to really not be a good starter you know
i mean nick foles is just like he's the
same thing as jacoby bersett he's that
guy that's oh he's a really good backup
but i'm not so sure he's a guy that we
want to be our starting quarterback for
17 16 games or 17 weeks you know so it
puts them in the same boat again i so i
don't see that happening i think that
they need to get somebody a little bit
more proven and that's where i look at
phillip rivers and think okay that makes
sense but if you have nick foles and
jacoby brisette you have two guys that
are kind of the same thing yeah nick
foles is just a little bit better
version of that um but i do think that
the colts without a doubt are going out
there to get somebody we know that i
think jacoby berset's done being the
starting quarterback and i think nick
foles is done being the starting
quarterback in jacksonville i've heard a
lot of the same things you are they're
going with gardner minshew he's their
guy
i spoke with frank reich last week on
the day that you had to quickly exit the
set yeah and i asked him near the end of
the interview about nick foles and he he
lit up there's still affection there's
still positivity they want a super bowl
together in philadelphia frank wright's
the head coach of the colts because of
nick foles to a certain extent now i
know that reich earned it through work
and perseverance but if falls doesn't
come in and play like he did late in the
2017 season and help deliver that super
bowl win frank reich is not the head
coach of the colts right now or at least
he wouldn't have been as of the start of
the 2018 season so i i think that that
uh it's possible and i think that when
you consider the money they have
invested in percent maybe this is a good
combination where you don't go out and
spend a ton of money on philip rivers to
whom they've been linked you spend
reasonable money on nick foles you take
him to indianapolis annapolis you let
him compete with jacoby brissett if
rasat wins fine foals will be a great
teammate and help him get better and
better and better and if foles wins
he'll who knows who knows right we've
seen nick foles twice in philadelphia be
spectacular we've seen him everywhere
else he's gone be not very good but here
he would be in indianapolis with a guy
who helped him be great enough to win a
super bowl i'm fascinated by what that
could become i'm kind of rooting for
that one frankly because i think it
could work for the colts and for nick
foles at
dez
why do people think justin herbert and
jordan love are so close i don't
understand why herbert gets no respect
chris your reaction well yeah i i do
there is a faction of people out there
that just want to crap on justin herbert
i don't know what it is you know i think
it's the it's the it's this what this is
what it is we have a number of people in
the sports world right now that they
just look at the bottom line stats
that's all they do so they go oh oregon
lost oh justin herbert only threw for
150 yards well he must be the reason
they lost man justin herbert can't win
big games in the pac-12 he just can't i
just read the stat line i didn't see any
of the game but i saw the stat line and
that was the one that jumped out to me
so he's got to be the reason they lose
now listen jordan love i like them i
have you know i haven't studied and deep
dived these guys yet i'm hoping to
actually start that today because i had
a little snap through with my my film um
and i in jordan love is he's going in
the first round as well justin herbert i
think all the issues that i hear people
talk about with justin herbert or more
times or not have to do with oregon's
offense and then i see people nitpicking
them on tv oh look he could have made
this throw or done this but yet they
don't show like other players where i'm
gonna go well here's a play that like
nobody in college football can make
somehow that gets cut out of the
highlight package when people want to
crap on this guy to me this guy has the
most potential to be the big time
superstar i mean not only with the size
but he's twitchy you saw what he was as
an athlete and i think again a lot of it
goes back to you know the the organ
offense it was it's one of the worst
offenses i saw as far as throwing
passing concepts on tv this year and i
saw a number of games with oregon this
year and just went well where does
anybody want justin herbert to throw the
ball there's nobody open i see five guys
and they're all covered and i just think
some of that has gotten there which i
think is hilarious that people crap on
him and then jordan love who throws 20
touchdowns and 17 interceptions nobody
has any concerns about him he's clean as
can be and that's where i just want to
go
what says so this is it's a false
narrative out there right now that i
don't i don't agree with and i'll be
able to give you more answers as i deep
dive into this whole thing
i want to know more about your film
snafu you buried the lead there what
happened
on it i had a
yeah i you know yeah i had some issues
that's coming i can't talk about it here
on air
but we're talking about a guy again
that's getting crapped on that ran
through for 32 touchdowns and six
interceptions and we're talking about oh
it's just not consistent it should be 40
to zero oh and then i see him run and
i'm gonna go whoa he's the best running
quarterback in the draft too like so
what what so you know there's a lot of
positives there i don't understand the
negative like hate on the guy
and he's a big dude six six we met him
very respectful yeah nice right i the
only the only negative i would have yeah
i know justin herbert is when we asked
him what quarterbacks he admired growing
up and he went straight for joey
harrington that was an odd answer no
doubt about it that was a stunner i
think that goes back to what's really
concerning people in the nfl circles
about justin herbert is just that he's
he's never been out of eugene oregon and
that's what scares people a lot is just
they feel like he's kind of living he's
bubble boy to a degree you remember
bubble boy on seinfeld i remember bubba
right he's not that kind of bubble boy
but he's in it he's been in a little bit
of a bubble and i think people that's
sort of people are a little worried
about uh as far as the biggest concern
with him is
all right next up at orion chuzz am i
crazy for thinking taysom hill could be
someone bill belichick would go forward
quarterback if brady leaves i'm guessing
that belichick would love the swiss army
knife aspect and the fairly modest cap
hit and look when we consider what
mobile quarterbacks have done to the
patriots over the years they finally
have a chance to go get a mobile
quarterback assuming that tom brady
moves on well i i do think like bill
belichick would love a guy like taysom
hill
him and josh mcdaniels could have a lot
of fun with that type of player but i
think the reality of the situation is
this what mike i mean
this is like sean payton's little pet
project and he loves him we know that
we've asked sean payton about him we can
see him light up when he talks about
taysom hill so you know yeah do i think
bill belichick would like him certainly
but there's just no freaking way he gets
out of new orleans and between what we
heard from drew brees and sean payton
they both want them back
yeah i agree with you completely and
look they're going to use a restricted
free agency tender and it's most likely
uh if not definitely gonna be a first
round tender and the saints are gonna
match whatever offer
that someone else would would sign
taysom hill to if he even signs an offer
sheet because that's the thing too what
offer sheet do you put in front of
taysom hill that would lock him up into
2021 and beyond that would be better
than just taking the 6 million this year
and franchise tag next year if the
saints ultimately can't sign into a
long-term deal he wants to be paid as a
franchise quarterback not as a
high-level jack of all trades so i don't
think he's going anywhere although i am
fascinated by the possibility of the
patriots getting a more mobile
quarterback and really anybody is more
mobile than tom brady given what mobile
quarterbacks have done to the patriots
over the years so on that note we're
going to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports